[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very huh do you wanna be friends
[Music]
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends do a dangerous quest
with all new faces
hello call me sage good move I made out
of sage and I am a sage so it works out
pretty well
I'm Patrick my name means toaster in
Celtic pretty sure it doesn't the most
amazing places look wouldn't worry about
us losing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you I love ironing to start ready
ready
popcorn nacho cheese fruit beer with red
licorice all right it's time we made a
new movie good idea Scoob but first we
need a trailer oh can you do the trailer
high voice let me give it a shot in the
world destroyed by evil discover the
epic origin story and the greatest team
of heroes
goodness is free
mystery nailed it
[Music]
hi-yah this mangy stray is coming with
me he's not a stray
okay then what's his name his name's
Scooby middle name doobie last name do
[Laughter]
would always be without you guys feel I
love it never take it off maybe don't do
that again I'm Fred this is Velma
hi they're not staff me hey I'm Shaggy
and this is scooby-doo nice to meet you
[Music]
hello
whoa whoa whoa Shaggy and Scooby were
taken do you realize where we are no
look a real man the clean modernists say
the cool-blue color palette
we're in Mikey did you say I can't nope
I said well can't you just like you
maybe this can lead us to Scooby and
Shaggy trace amounts of moustache oil
twelve-year-old scotch
the bad guy my dad hey boy I must be a
man today kneel before me that's okay I
have a gift I'm your dad he said to give
you this when you were both over 16 it's
a wizard step dad was a wizard what your
dad was an accountant
this spell brings him back for one whole
day dad will be back
watch Rock way back to life that's not
possible it is with this I'm gonna meet
dad
ah hisses legs I definitely remember Ted
having a top part uh what did I do
hi we only have 24 hours to bring the
rest of him back hey Dad you look just
like I remember
[Music]
banker you seek
you come to the right pattern
[Music]
we might be out of gas but it says we
have a full tank that doesn't work
growth spell we grow the can and then
the gas inside will grow with it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then look at your boy
sleepy night night Blanche sterling the
legendary spy who's always dressed to
impress
Walter Beckett graduated MIT at 15 and
works in the tech innovations lab there
are so many gadgets I want to test in
the field for example the inflatable
hook kind of a personal protection
device I've been developing this is a
vile waste of taxpayer dollars this is
your next objective none of our agents
can get close to him
[Music]
I have something that can help it's
called biodynamic concealment imagine if
I can make you disappear hey Lance look
at me look at you I could see my butt
and your face at the same time that is
so cool
being a pigeon could make you an even
better spy pigeons are everywhere nobody
notices them as you can see in slow
motion
that was tight did anyone else see a
pigeon and [ __ ] who flight up to 92
miles per hour don't you throw me
officers
he'll figure it out
all right Kimora starting it's about to
get messy
time to go sleepy night
I miss my hands I gotta stay you're
squeezing - Oh what happens in the
submarine
stays in a submarine what would you want
to be known for on earth
we only have a short time on this planet
you want to become the person that you
were born to be
don't waste your time on all the junk of
life like doing
spend your precious hours doing what
will bring out the real you
the brilliant passionate youth
that's ready to contribute something
meaningful into this world
I got the gig I really need a haircut
today man can you get man
[Music]
[Music]
so what do you want to be remembered for
probably for doing this funny cowboy
dance
[Music]
[Applause]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in what would I do
without you you'll always have me how
that seemed weird to you she seems like
Elsa there's this voice voice what does
that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have found sense
I'm going with you Anna no excuse me I
climb to the North Mountain survived a
frozen heart and saved you from my
ex-boyfriend so you know I'm coming
that's normal
where are we
how did you get in the forest then this
party for her has impossible where did
you learn magic
I can't just follow me into fire and
don't run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa more than anyone
or anything
[Music]
quick question is the whole putting up
to mortal danger gonna be a regular
thing
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it
hello I just wanted you to know this has
been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest but
also the most thrilling heads up I'm a
Duke
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world we're headed upriver lagrimas
de Cristal mr. Huron travel come on not
a good time my brother looking for
passage upriver please go away I have a
lot of money ever you believe in legends
do you believe in curses - you're gonna
beg minutes are back well I look forward
to disappointing you 10,000 to bring you
there alive Dead is 15,000 why should I
pay me dead
dad I'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady there we go
oh sorry Frank it's alright strong form
I dunno swim you put the river cruising
you can't swim the price just went out
being a street dog isn't so bad at all
he's a champ
I'm free to be whoever I want to be walk
wherever I want to walk hey hi are you
two twins I'm her husband pal ah ha eat
whatever I want to keep he's a champ you
know what fine
just remember I got this the
old-fashioned way I stole it
snob hell there we go I got my collar
let me just take a little guess here
you're the center of your peoples
universe right you could say that your
families just don't please don't
well that's basically all over now
you're about to be replaced
replace me I don't think so
lady this is Lulu
[Music]
when the baby moves in the dog moves out
[Music]
help me get this thing off this way
totally safe I'm not gonna do that
keep it crazy you don't know that happen
Wow
what is this place
but a great big world out there with no
fence around it
[Music]
every day could be an adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I tell you a story
it's the story of an orphan girl from a
faraway land he was sent to live a
mysterious house
[Music]
and what if I were to tell you she
discovered something magical
something secret
[Music]
would you believe me
[Music]
if you cause me trouble or have you sent
wait in an instant
[Music]
and you were hiding something this
garden it's capable to get stored my
things now will you believe in the magic
[Music]
[Music]
yo oh yes my furry little reindeer my
name is Noel Kringle Martin princess my
partridge in a pear tree underwear needs
washing
oh well then my Christmas wish has been
granted Christmas runs in my family my
dad was Santa and now it's my brother
next turn to wear the hat stocking full
of coal if I've ever seen one he saved a
kitten from a tree nice well here
brother I'd be ready by Christmas of
course he's a creme sometimes I dream
about getting out well you can't be
Santa if you're having a nervous
breakdown
you need to get away for the weekend the
first time in 2,000 years
Santa has disappeared I just said he
should take the weekend off we must have
a new center Gabriel
Kringle me I'm in the tech department
and loving it what about a rescue
mission do you mind telling me what
you're doing I'm going to get my brother
and you're coming with me
stay right where you are we are looking
for Santa Claus
you don't tell anybody who you are where
are you think I'm gonna tie the front
four or you came from sir it's a
privilege to wear that suit put some
pants on
so lobby Christmas Eve has less than 48
hours away this could be the perfect
time to start an online delivery
platform gotta find Santa thousands
appears to be of jingle bells until
liver boys and we must make sure nothing
changes that
I like your pants they're jolly they're
yoga pants like yours these are my
yogurt pants and no yoga pants I love
yogurt pants don't want facing reindeer
please wow that's a big deal in here
our word has never been in more danger
[Music]
human greed is what drove us underground
all those years ago to escape from your
rapacious appetite
[Music]
I warn you boy
[Music]
you are not prepared for the truth
behind what you seek
[Music]
now you will believe
artemus fair
[Music]
[Music]
we are gathered here today to join B and
Thomas in holy matrimony you're taking
this so well he's a good man you hated
this guy
you've grown very close welcoming a new
parent not that close so father father
no you're not my father sorry are you
it's really the rabbit story I just
wrote it down
look it's Peter Rabbit oh I hate that
I'm the face of this he's naughty what I
knew Peter that depends who's asking
Peter told you he has it in for me he
was talking to all of us I'm talking to
you Peter
specifically stay out of trouble if
that's who they think I am maybe I'd be
better off without them
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
or you look good eat buddy you return me
I know pretty good eat apparently I'm a
body fat is your name Peter Rabbit yeah
I was best friends with your dad my
name's Barnabas you're a fierce bad
rabbit just like why rather rabbits back
in their burrows snug as a bug in a rug
spread out
[Music]
still in them and that's what adults
shouldn't do kid stuff
[Music]
hey watch it a young princess finally
meets her dragon what are dragon and a
green Lander to be Iceland anyway he's
on a quest I can help you
oh you think trust me join Lily hi
Beluga
dangerous as they raced to stop an evil
snowman dragon dragon what a joy to give
you your fire
there
in our dragon a story of fire
eyes
and unforgettable adventures
[Music]
the fire is Mackenzie Ziegler is ice
princess I see your place for a while
no come on Mick Mick why did you order
this
I didn't there big problem so cute he
has to go back to his parents - probably
worried sick by now
calls for a big adventure pandas live in
bamboo forests far off in the south if
we sailed down the river
it just might be doable I could help
with the supplies no the mission I'm so
come on me you're too scared I'm on a
quest to find this baby's parents want
to tag along looks like I finally found
a friend what are you waiting for
haha from a writer look Madagascar
everybody freeze way ahead of you
[Music]
becomes a story of friendship will be
like Batman and Robin
like d'Artagnan in the three musketeers
like Dolce and Gabanna
teamwork and family look everyone part
baby is all grown up featuring the
voices of Drake Bell and Pauly Shore
Travon the big trip
[Music]
[Music]